the Joe Rogan experience well isn't it
also partly because the discussion is
out there and the discussion is a very
attractive one the discussion of one of
the reasons why you haven't gotten by in
this world is because of inequality and
because of some sort of systemic racism
or systemic sexism or systemic
homophobia or transphobia and it becomes
when you give people an option to find
an excuse yeah they gravitate towards
that we create safe space right and you
coddle yeah and you make you mean all
these pieces are in places many many
moving parts right and I think all these
little pieces are in place where where
we also have these massive echo chambers
because of social media we have these
people that you know they find
ideologically similar human beings and
they bounce off of each other but these
were all real problems like I have an
intersex friend I was eating somebody
whose indeterminate between male and
female physiologically so okay let's
imagine that they have it's some
karyotype XY profile right and that the
developmental process did not produce
unambiguous genitalia okay okay is that
a hermaphrodite okay okay this is a
person I think is pretty terrific and I
look at all the forms that say
male/female and I just you know my heart
sinks like we're not even in trans here
we're talking about somebody whose
biological card that they were dealt
could have been you could have been me
right and through no no choices at all
this person is being shoehorned into a
paradigm which puts them at an increased
risk of suicide and it breaks my heart
and we should change it we should break
the male-female dichotomy absolutely now
I have a different feeling about trans
but if we solve the issue of intersex
which is not pressuring just accepting
that's some tiny percentage of the
population which is not vanishingly
small it's just not large is neither
unambiguously male and female in terms
of genotype phenotype concordance we
will do most of the work necessary to
take care of our trans folks who are
suffering to my
now trans is a much more rich world
because there are a million different
issues taking place in trans and they're
all conflated you know part of it
because of developmental biology part of
it because gender really in some sense
is socially constructed in a way that
like when people say mathematics is
socially constructed I have to reject it
you know I and I give this example of
like kilts and loonies from Scotland in
India our skirts but they're not female
in those places so you have to learn
about male and female relative to the
codification in your society and the
issues of what are our what are our
obligations to recognize hey this is
really a female mind in a male body
versus this is a regular mind in a
regular body but needs instruction all
of these things are conflated and I was
really hoping that we if you know if we
used intersex as the test case to break
them the binary because the binary is an
oppression there's no question in my
mind about it well how is it an
oppression because it let's imagine that
I let's say I have persistent malaria
inducts syndrome so i'm phenotypically
on the outside male and I go to my
doctor he says hey you've got a uterus
what yeah yeah you have a uterus okay
that's an exotic situation maybe I want
to identify male you know because the
outside equipment looks male it's it's a
it's a weird situation maybe the idea is
we're talking more extremely rare
circumstances does that really define it
as being oppressive like what like what
is for for a friend of mine who is in
neither situation yeah it's oppressive
but I mean is it a president some people
are born paralyzed right some people are
born with like serious neurological
diseases that don't allow them to be
motile that's right like what is it
oppressive if people are just recognized
like most people recognized as being
able to walk if there was no category
called
dis disabled right okay like or in a
wheelchair okay no category all right
yeah so you've got somebody who's got a
spinal cord injury and you have people
saying alright everybody walked
way what do you mean you can't walk get
up
why are you lazy that's what it sounds
like to me like it's one thing to
recognize that not everybody is in the
standard category mm-hmm but it's
another thing to hard-code like hard
code where are you talking about Java
yes forms yeah the Federals are becoming
a problem there's a binary it says male
or female yeah let's imagine it doesn't
say other or prefer not to say okay so
we're just talking about filling out
forms which is how often does that take
place in your life often enough that it
represents oppression well you have to
let me define motion or female
emotionally emotionally I think this is
oppression oppression yeah really isn't
it done under the interests of defining
people simply because for the most part
yeah dealing with males and females and
it's sort of the most part they're just
trying to figure out what's what for
their statistics yeah but you know again
this is this is fun I'm glad you're
asking me these questions because
usually I have to be on the other side
of this issue and this is really where
my heart is which is I care about these
people and I know that in every single
conservative society in the world there
are accommodations made for the failure
of simple binaries to accommodate the
population there's no society this I
there's no society is so conservative
that they've sorted the world into male
and female you know the famous example
of in Iran of the Ayatollah making a
fatwa that said it's fine to have gender
reassignment right we have to recognize
that every single population produces
gender sexual ambiguity but it's not
also to get around the idea of
homosexuality being a grievous crime
because like I believe in Iran it's
illegal to have homosexual activity but
you can have gender reassignment so if
you're a gay man you can choose to
become a female that's true but there's
also a thriving gay scene in Tehran you
know do they have to recognize this but
yeah and there are all sorts of
persecution you know that there was a
situation in India
where I'm you know I have more
experience where you would say oh those
two people are confirmed bachelors you
know that they're so dedicated to their
professions that there's no room for
family and they live together right so
like traditional societies have
everybody accommodates homosexuality and
failures of simple gender binaries and
you know I always bring up the example
of Turkish where Turkish doesn't
hard-code the third person singular
pronoun as male or female it just has
one pronoun for both so thank you for
giving me the opportunity to show where
my heart actually has been this entire
time which is I believe this is
oppressive and I don't think that it
oppresses that many people but I believe
that it's an important oppression that
we have to realize that we hard-coded
and that's what generated a lot of the
feelings before we get to trans you can
simply say from the position of intersex
that the world is a richer place than
male and female and people say oh it six
six versus XY it's like no it isn't it
just isn't it for the most part is if
for the most part it is so in terms of
it is it has been an edge case to deal
with but that edge case is important to
me right does the edge case are they are
human beings that are not only then I
actually okay I like people who are
outside of the norms I think that
probably a larger percentage of those
people are going to be more interesting
people because they're forged in the
fire hmm so it's not just a case that
you know do you want to chase a couple
of edge cases everybody with a really
different experience is more important
to me than everyone with the standard
experience I think we have to keep take
care of the standard case but I'm
absolutely interested in outliers in
edge cases
[Applause]